this meme i saw recently if you want to
feel bad about yourself as a programmer
realize that
one person wrote railroad tycoon i think
that's the name of the game it's this
cool little builder game one person
wrote it in assembly
so for like from scratch and for people
who don't know it kind of looks like a
sim city type game it's a city builder
but obviously centered on railroads and
there's a nice graphics the three
dimension all that kind of stuff all the
things
all the rich colorful things you would
imagine for
for a three-dimensional video game all
written in assembly meaning the lowest
level code next to binary yeah which is
uh fascinating and that's the that you
had to notice the magic
at that low level at that time you
didn't have all the graphics you didn't
have all the
like apis and all the sample codes no
stack overflow no internet none of that
you just had you had to know registers
you know had to know the op codes and
you had to imagine the world in your
brain of the memory structures and
everything of there's no visualization
you visualized it all yourself right and
so that was magic but then the next part
of the magic of where i got hooked even
further was like i'm doing these little
things
and then electronic arts came out for
the apple too so i got an apple ii and
electronic arts came out and i was
programming and doing basic and making
my own games
but then there were two games that
really blew my mind one was
pinball construction set
and the other one was music construction
set and these were both places where i
could create pinball games and i could
create musical scores because i loved
music and i could then play them right
and so when you had that
you were like oh there's something very
different so i could create myself
but then there was others that create
tools so you could create at a visual
level and then you would read the back
stories because electronics arts back in
the day it was one programmer who would
program those things you know each of
those things and you could read their
backstories it was literally like like a
musician or someone else like you could
read rick rubin's like here's a thing
they tell you all that stuff and there
was one guy
who wrote music construction set he
wrote it all in assembly and he was 16
years old wow
and i went and i was probably 12 or 13
at the time
and i went oh my
if he was able to do this and had
published right and this amazing tool
was created i'm like what could i do and
so then it it just kept building off of
that but really it was those seminal
things first the introduction and then
the you know the power through
programming and turning these things
into what you wanted to turn it into and
you didn't have to be
40 50 years old and have you know phds
and then i was like okay this is really
cool
you